Hey Conan here again, and
we're trying to raise money
for a good cause on the holidays,
Great way to help children
during the holiday season.
Donate, there should be information
at the bottom of the screen.
If there isn't, I'll fire
the person responsible,
on Christmas Eve.
That's the kind of guy I am.
All right, I got some
great people handling
this today with me,
Mr. Jimmy Vivino,
we got James, The Worm, Wormworth,
what an awful nickname, on drums.
And then Mike Merritt on the bass guitar.
Then helping us out, Skills is gonna play
that jingly jangly thing.
Went to, yes, nine years
of music college for that.
Anyway, there are only
two great Christmas songs
in the world, we all know that.
One, of course Handel's Messiah,
the other by The Kinks.
Let's try that second one.
Doctor, take us away.
(hard Christmas music)
One, two, three, four.
♪ When I was four I
believed in Santa Claus ♪
♪ Though I knew it was my dad ♪
♪ I would hang up my
stockings at Christmas ♪
♪ Open my presents and I'd be glad ♪
♪ But the last time I
played Father Christmas ♪
♪ I stood outside a department store ♪
♪ A gang of kids came over and mugged me ♪
♪ And knocked my reindeer to the floor ♪
♪ They said Father Christmas,
give us the money ♪
♪ Don't mess around
with those silly toys ♪
♪ We'll beat you up if
you don't hand it over ♪
♪ We want your bread so
don't make us annoyed ♪
♪ Give all the toys to
the little rich boys ♪
(strong guitar music)
♪ Don't give my brother
a Steve Austin outfit ♪
♪ Don't give my sister a cuddly toy ♪
♪ We don't want a jigsaw
or Monopoly money ♪
♪ We only want the real McCoy ♪
♪ They said Father Christmas,
give us the money ♪
♪ We'll beat you up if
you make us annoyed ♪
♪ Father Christmas, give us the money ♪
♪ Don't mess around
with those silly toys ♪
♪ But give my daddy a
job 'cause he needs one ♪
♪ He's got lots of mouths to feed ♪
♪ But if you've got one,
I'll have a machine gun ♪
♪ So I can scare all
the kids on the street ♪
♪ Father Christmas, give us some money ♪
♪ We got no time for your silly toys ♪
♪ We'll beat you up if
you don't hand it over ♪
♪ We want your bread so
don't make us annoyed ♪
♪ Give all the toys to
the little rich boys ♪
(strong guitar music)
♪ Have yourself a very merry Christmas ♪
♪ Have yourself a good time ♪
♪ But remember the kids who got nothing ♪
♪ While you're drinking down your wine ♪
(drum music)
(electric guitar music)
♪ Father Christmas, give us some money ♪
♪ We got no time for your silly toys ♪
♪ Father Christmas, please hand it over ♪
♪ We'll beat you up so
don't make us annoyed ♪
♪ Let's go ♪
♪ Father Christmas give us the money ♪
♪ Don't mess around
with those silly toys ♪
♪ We'll beat you up if
you don't hand it over ♪
♪ We want your bread, so
don't make us annoyed ♪
♪ Give all the toys to
the little rich boys ♪
(strong music)